seems like you guys are all influenced
by some sort of trailer trailers
trailers work right trailer trailer you
drive a lot of inspiration from you know
like from what you see yeah for me it
was GI Joe and then I got what brats are
they in yeah
that's a good question
[Music]
welcome back to an insanely special
episode of careful boys today we have
with us three remarkable human beings
that are all different special forced
branches wow um it's it's an honor to
have them here if you can starting uh
with trunk can you please introduce
yourselves and the special force branch
that you're affiliated with hi my name
is Trump I'm a former Army Ranger
um Michael Dowd and I was a Navy SEAL
I'm Don Tran and I was a marine reader
very cool yay
all right so uh for the people out there
um I think a lot of times people they
they hear Special Operations and they
just hear okay for sure these guys are
super Elite can you get each kind of go
into
um what you guys did and what was your
mission and then uh maybe from that
people can kind of like discern the
difference maybe starting with you yeah
so the 75th Ranger regiment is tasked
with direct action we're basically a
light infantry unit but more advanced
work uh tasks to go out there kill
capture bad guys during the G white War
all the way up to now and this has led
on to other missions that we're capable
of
and most of you guys are airborne
getting into yeah we're Airborne
qualified you know being able to operate
in the Hilo being able to fast whip off
helicopters and stuff like that
and then what about you kind sir
uh if you've seen the movie Navy Seals
with Charlie Sheen that's pretty much it
uh no we're uh chairs of the Sun with
Bruce Willis it's the exact same oh okay
exact same those are Navy Seals I saw
Delta Force with Chuck Norris yeah
that's different we don't have it
so would you say most of you got your
your missions start from the water or no
no
like when when the 20-year War kicked
off in in the desert everyone kind of
moved over there
um but our primary specialty was uh
direct action Mission so going in uh to
a place like a house capturing killing
so it sounds very similar yeah
kidnap not kidnap the the arresting yeah
like that yeah both those okay okay
we'll figure out the difference after
that Don what do you do yeah and then uh
the Marine Raiders started in World War
II as a small unit that specialized in
amphibious raids on small rubber crafts
but now you know when we reformed it in
uh 2006 it was just more stock and then
we went to the same 20-year war and
deploying over to the Middle East so
um direct action special reconnaissance
and then really the fit Mission which is
foreign internal defense so training a
partner Force to go fight with them so
this is like is that too much overlap
like all the branches kind of doing the
same [__] there's
there's like one fight and everyone's
just trying to figure out how they can
all get in all of it and uh I think
that's what happened is it like the
movies where crime happens in the FBI
the local police and then everybody gets
together they go I got jurisdiction I
got jurisdiction and then like
everybody
[Music]
wants to be the cool unit that gets the
mission to go over to the direct action
missions which is the coolest one this
direct action a euphemism for something
else it's like hearing hits raids can be
yeah so at the the special force level
every like Navy uh Marine whatever right
that's their unit of Special Force right
like like like yours is Marine and then
that's and then do they all work
together or do they have their own teams
like the if this was the NBA right
you're like the Bulls and you're like
the Lakers or whatever but do they ever
Harlem Globetrotter well like the
All-Star Game the All-Star yeah yeah so
there's so Socom which is actually the
like the headquarter unit for all these
Special Operations here so calm like the
game or the novel right exactly and then
there's also the jsoc which is like the
even higher level which is the joint
ones joint Special Operations Command
that's when they like don't fight they
fight with each other
and Joe to top it off there is a unit
the unit Delta it's actually they
recruit from all branches so there were
guys in the Delta Force units they're
Navy uh that are uh marines that are Air
Force they they open recruitment to
everybody damn and do they all do the
same jobs like arresting assassination
like there's no specialty not
assassination
yeah direct action
direct action
well excuse me I come from the gang
world
so um maybe we go down the line too like
explaining what uh made you guys each
join the respective uh branches to so
starting with oh we heard your story
we'll start this one yep absolutely
um
well in the Marine why did you even join
the Marines to begin with versus army
navy Air Force whatever oh I was a kind
of a mess up in in high school so just
trying to get away from that life and
trying to do something new and something
special but why Marine Corps versus Navy
or Coast Guard I saw that the dragon
slang commercial where there's a race
that was that was like
yeah people always said the Marines were
the hardest the coolest yeah the most
badass
[Laughter]
and did you know you're gonna go into
Special Operations from the get or was
it after you joined you're like oh [__]
there's more levels to this stuff yeah
uh I don't even know what I don't think
the Marine rate or actually the MARSOC
just started when I joined so I joined
in 2006. um but I didn't know anything
about it and one day I just stumbled
across from one of the trailers and
there was some guys in like different
uniforms they had like Velcro on cooler
boots and stuff like that so I was like
man I want to do that so I walked in
there and started the process of
becoming a Raider a marine Raider yeah
and then what about you Mike uh since I
was a kid like 12 13 years old it was a
Discovery Channel documentary of uh Navy
Seals I don't remember being like that's
what I want to do and my mom was like no
way just 12 13 yeah yeah it was I don't
know like and it was just always in my
head and then it just took a while for
me to you know make that happen but
seems like you guys are all influenced
by some sort of trailer trailers
trailers work right trailer trailer you
drive a lot of inspiration from you know
like from what you see yeah you know
yeah for me it was GI Joe and then I got
what brats are they in yeah I don't even
know that's a good question
super Elite so for you knowing that at
12 did you already start like physically
preparing for it I don't know if I was
physically preparing at 12 but I
definitely had it in the back of my mind
with everything I was trained for like
when I would play paintball I'm like I'm
maybe Seal training right I don't even
know what that meant but but yeah yeah I
think it is the the marketing yeah which
is probably why we make so many [__]
movies and uh am I love to swear yeah as
much as you want yeah [__] yeah
you could say assassinations too uh I
would maybe call it like terminating
like
bugs
yeah yeah yeah
termination
and then what about you I started with
the VHS that my mom's friend sent to my
mom about her son graduating Ranger
school then really what Don said to the
lineage of the Rangers all with dating
back when they used to fight the Native
Americans of Roger Rangers so we're at
the whole lineage behind that and you
know World War II Point D Hawk when they
stormed the beach of Omaha Beach and all
that that's that's what got me like if
this is something I want to do wow how
come you guys didn't did you guys ever
like go maybe I should have did this one
or like you guys were just stuck in
exactly what you wanted
this ultimate question yeah I mean if
you've seen Navy Seals with Charlie
Sheen you would know come on come on
dude I gotta add that to my watch list
dude it's really good really you guys
never seen it I saw Rambo and I was
hella like I want to go but then I felt
like if I was there I'd be like the
Vietnamese bad guy and then they'll be
shooting at me so you're like I don't
like that you're like I don't like this
Charlie's
Charlie's in The Wire yeah because I I
was actually gonna join the Army and
then I went down to you know all the
recruiting stations are usually like
back to back and then I talked to him I
was ah he gives me weird Vibes then I
went to Navy and that guy kind of gave
me like used car salesman Vibes and then
I went to the marine recruiter and I was
like hello hello and then there was no
one there I'm like what the [__] she's
empty and then this guy comes out from
underneath the desk he's like trying to
join the Marines I was like oh I think I
found my people
not real yeah the Montebello
and then he was already in like um daddy
just killing all my incredibles in here
right now
uh PE shorts and then uh I think either
a Montebello High School or sure high
school t-shirt he goes all right make
this quick because I'm gonna go coach
wrestling and I was like dude this guy
doesn't give a [__] about me I like him
because everyone else is like come back
we'll we'll get you we'll grab some
lunch I felt like I was getting whined
and dined you know this one I was like
this guy don't give a [__] Straight
Shooters
so for all all three you guys like you
knew what you wanted to do
um you didn't join the military and go
oh this is there's even more higher
levels like it was just straight from
the beginning like I want to be a seal I
want to be a ranger like I didn't no oh
okay figure it out on the way yeah so
for you guys like when you learned about
it
um did anybody show you the ropes of
like how to get there like you got to
take this you got to go this way or like
did you talk to like a like a military
counselor or somebody that that helps
you with your career path just your
leadership you know like guys I actually
looked out for you they cared for you
they wanted to put you in the right path
um so that was like your commanding
officer you just asked him like no no
none of those guys no nobody that no
officers like enlisted guys that were
actually on the ground like in the fight
with you those guys yeah and then so
they'll be the ones that kind of be like
yeah you got to take this class or this
thing yeah I mean if they've done it
before then it's easy for them to kind
of guide you in the right path and um to
do but in the military like these guys
and there's so many different options
and different jobs that you can do even
on the small teams that we were on so
what's the coolest [__] in your job that
you would say uh like let's say you had
your kid is like 10 or 12. like what
would be the coolest story you would
tell them about what you did like each
one of you guys
do you guys have like oh like this is
what I would say to inspire my kid about
what I did to join the military no just
a cool story yeah
um like your dad is going down a rope
with one hand and I was swinging my arm
like you know just like what would be
like what would be like to paint the
hero's image for your kids yeah yeah
trailer for your kids yeah yeah build a
trailer build your own trailer you just
show them Navy Seals just watch Charlie
I'm Charlie Sheen in this yeah my last
appointment we were in the Philippines I
know it's like originally went over
there to go train uh like the Filipino
Marines and some other of their special
operation guys over there but in the
middle of the deployment there was uh a
city called morale and Isis took over
that City and we got to help take it
back there's Filipino ices the entire
like yeah Filipino Muslims the entire
deployment were like in plain clothes
you know you got to grow beers and all
that stuff if you wanted to so that was
kind of like a really cool experience
but on uh to where like to wear like
civilian clothes yeah and clothes yeah
but on Wikipedia if you look it up it
says a Navy SEAL platoon was there so
you didn't get the credit you gotta edit
that out tell Wikipedia that's wrong I
was there make a suggestion but it's not
a good thing it's like where they got
the information wrong and then you guys
are the ones that actually know
um I don't think it matters in that
aspect of it but
um yeah that was a pretty cool story
no because we gotta help take it back
you know I was like so I'm gonna beat
our son okay I'm like
so you wore jeans you think that's cool
dad
you 14 year old
civilian clothes these guys don't like
it on missions Uncle Joe just told me he
toured Australia and there's chicks that
went on a bottom in the hotel room yeah
how old's your kid that you're telling a
story 14 12. all right I don't like that
story better
but a six-year-old maybe he'll be like
wow you could wear a fake beard
were you still during that mission were
you still in charge of the um what is it
like you used to do these like signals
to get bombs yeah I was the j-tech yeah
JTAG okay oh yeah can you guys hear what
specific role you played in your unit
yeah your job oh yeah can you redescribe
the JTAG again from yeah it's just uh so
you're like a you talk to the aircraft
and coordinate the aircrafts in the
ballast space so whether it needs to be
used for uh surveillance to check out
maybe potential targets or whatever it
is or to actually call an airstrike
and what does jtac stand for joint
terminal attack controller so are you
like your job is like you're out there
and you're just like all right I see
them coordinates
or Mike Jones
and then like
or like whatever yeah I mean honestly
exactly like that yeah so and that's
Jake jtech j-tech yeah like I'm the one
wearing jeans 20 feet in front of me you
have to mark yourself somehow
how many um on average like for a
mission like that how many times do you
have to call in an airstrike like I mean
it really depends on the mission are you
doing a reconnaissance mission where
hopefully you don't have to drop
anything if they found you and you're
you know in a small team
um or if you're like on a direct action
hit with the Rangers I say that because
those guys are always doing those hits
but you might have like an AC-130
flying around and anybody that's played
Call of Duty you guys know yeah and that
is like ultimate Firepower on a mission
yeah so it just depends really
what about you Michael would be like
this story to tell your kid show how
cool dad was
um I I think my my first deployment in
Iraq uh we were doing night raids so
every night we'd go out and you know
capture people and uh just the idea of
like night after night going into
people's houses
and like occasionally waking them up
with your hand over their face
and taking them out and just
um
I think my kids would be like holy [__]
that was cool that's way cooler than
mine
Uncle Mike is so cool I'm trying to the
Navy dad as cool as that is then I would
follow up with
how many people
pissed and [__] themselves from the fear
and you as a new guy
would all our new guys we would then put
on gloves and have to search the the
poopy pants oh so find anything good oh
geez I think for like the senior guys
that was a really cool Mission and then
when you go home and you're like taking
off poop gloves yeah
um because they make the new guys do all
the poopy work see people don't talk
about the poop Arrangements people leave
that outside in the movie yeah
he would have to fly back you have to
fly back with poopy gloves and you're
yeah I take them off
the choice I made
so if your job was the the phone in like
strike guy you still had to do poopy
Duty if your job was that no but my job
wasn't that in Iraq oh so it's different
depending on oh okay okay
it's not like like you get one thing and
that's your that's your specialty it's
typically overlapping so he probably has
like three or four other calls that he's
not mentioning and then I would have
three or four yeah and then he would be
primary Jay attack I might be secondary
and then I might be primary Intel and
then if I get shot he could take over so
we over we overlap it in case somebody
you know goes down right what are some
other qualifications you have because so
far dad you're lame yeah
I was a Communications guy on my team so
took care of all the radios I wish I had
a different Dad yeah
[Laughter]
batch like do you have cook or like I am
not I don't have a cook badge but we do
cook a lot together as a team what are
the yeah what are the main
qualifications that make like a special
operations guy like what's like super
important like the top like three to
five everybody has their own uh school
or whatever that is to get through like
the seals have the buds and you guys
have your grass program right and then
we have ours is uh what's called ITC or
individual training course that's like
the basic to get actually be a ranger be
a seal or be a Raider so that's like one
of the ultimate cool ones then whatever
your insertion platforms after right yep
yeah so you jump or you dive or whatever
that is your specific unit has to
specialize in
um so different units have Specialties
like hey we need some amphibious dudes
or like we need some jumper dudes like
oh
yeah but it could so you could all be uh
like Marine Raider but then it's like
the amphibious Raiders yeah we would
have a guy team or a jump team
um I don't know how there's a split up
oh
so what what where was your team can you
say we had a jump team
um for one deployment and then we did a
dive team for another deployment so you
switch sometimes yeah depending where
you deploy what your job needs to be to
uh overseas so what do you jump or dive
or both both yeah that's tight wow [__]
yeah damn I got I gotta I got a crazy
one do you do you guys all have like a
crazy like near-death experience or is
it like every day
like do you have one who was just like
dude that was like bro
you know or you're just like every day
is like that the description so you know
how to up your story
this
yeah I mean I remember one hit that we
did was a night raid weed explosive
reach we hit we secured the the ground
level we're making our way up the spiral
sterile case because we hear [__]
individuals on top uh we were in the
stack moving up we saw one hand drop a
[__] grenade like no like [__] it
landed right by my buddy's [__] foot
but it didn't thank God it didn't go off
he kicked it it was a dud it didn't go
off so we went upstairs so this big dude
saw us come what he did was he ended up
grabbing his buddy and Sheltering him he
wouldn't let him go so we're like doing
everything to get get him [__] off
they're like get the [__] off get the
[__] up or like hit him with the [__]
butt sack of a rifle but he wouldn't let
go then one of our team guys was like
hey get out the way so we made a path
and do Square it up and kick them right
into [__] nuts from the back oh
kicked them so hard that one of his
testicles went up inside his [__]
thing so when we brought him in with the
medic had to [__] be like yeah you
got you kicked him so hard as [__]
nuts retreated into his [__] play at
the like shake it back
oh yeah that was like near-death
experience for me I was like [__] a
[__] grenade also you're lucky yeah
that's right that's your second what's
the dud rate I know the dud rape you
have a good luck charm on your teeth I
don't even [__] know what it was it's
probably one of those piece of shits for
sure man
so we had a few like diving close calls
uh because every time you dive
underwater whether it's training or
anywhere it's always real and uh but
that I was never really scared I don't
like flying and I had a close call one
time and it was at Iraq and we we took
off at night and all of a sudden this
like bright explosion out the window of
the C-130 happened boom a fireball and
all of a sudden we're like four or 500
feet off the ground and the plane just
started like swerving and swerving and
we're like we're not gaining altitude
and if you already don't like flying
this isn't like turbulence this is like
oh [__] here we go it got so it got
attacked with a rocket or something well
you have no idea there's no like
intercom like you know please take your
seats
you're just like kissing your ass
goodbye and you know what it what did I
plan in my will who's gonna get what and
then the plane turns and it starts
heading back and I and it looked like
we're gonna we're gonna make it and we
ended up landing and uh on land yeah
landed landed back at the airport
um at the base and then it turned out
that we had hit a bird on takeoff and
when the bird hit the engine made like
some kind of flare the chaff which is
also like bright fire had gone off uh
this is what we were told at least and
there's this massive Fireball from it
and then you know one of the engines
went dead and so it actually was
okay and the whole reason the pilot was
doing this was he was like testing the
controls and but when you're not privy
to that info yeah that was just like I
don't need the [__] like
yeah so the pilot was calm he knew what
he was doing but then on the back
everyone's like holy [__] what the [__]
what's going on yeah some more common
than others I'm like on the other
Spectrum or I'm just like
you know Frozen I mean if you're in a
war zone the first thing that would come
to my mind is it got hit by a rocket or
something like 100 right that's exactly
what it looked like yeah like I'm flying
Delta and then like trying to go to
he's on Delta Delta Force and I'm on
Delta Airlines like trying to go to
Houston it's like boom and I'm thinking
oh yeah it's probably a bird you know
but then like for you it's probably like
that must have been crazy worst case
scenario [__] that that's probably like
the worst feeling that can happen
because at least on the ground I begin
to a gun fight we can control it by
returning fire yeah when you're on a
bird and that [__] happens you're like I
I can't do anything yeah it's like God
you know take Jesus Take the Wheel like
up please yeah it's like that
helplessness man I can't imagine so many
other ways I'd rather die like yeah 100
try to get shot yeah way way more yeah
way more do you have a cool story to end
this segment dad and do it in three
minutes because it might the camera
might cut oh we were in uh Arizona doing
um a training
um Mission or whatever for this thing
called WTI which is like weapons tactics
or something for the Marine Corps like
the Marine Corps Top Gun School super
like inserting a ground for us but we're
not to see age 53 and we're on target at
night time with the ch-53 it's a
helicopter it's like the big loader that
can carry tanks and stuff like that
heavy loader but we were coming in on
insert and blacked out and the pilots
were coming in and it was a brown out
situation with the sand and everything
was kicking up so he didn't see a
building in front of him so he flew the
helicopter into the building the top
rotors hit the building and then I was
in the back and I was uh the Hearst
master so I was in charge of getting
everybody off the aircraft in time so I
did the 30 second call I unclip and I'm
like helping the guy look put the ramp
down and as he was hitting that
um
all of a sudden the tail rotors bouncing
back and forth up and down like really
really I think I bounce up and down from
the helicopter at least like six or
seven times like your whole back hit the
top
oh my God and then the tail rotor
actually broke off of the helicopter
holy [__] yeah
[Laughter]
that's my dad guys that's my dad
you got it back you got it back so it
was still blacked out the lights didn't
work on the helicopter we had to get
everybody off and the tail rotor was
still spinning and then we were
unloading everybody and we had like a
partner Nation for us which was like
just some regular CB Marines or engineer
Marines come off and like luckily I put
my nods on time because the kid was
about to walk into Nazis or night vision
or night vision on yeah yeah thanks for
that exciting yeah
pretty bad concussion after though Jesus
[__] oh geez when it landed it was on
the building no it was like coming in on
insert so he didn't level out enough and
one of the front sensors was broken so
he doesn't level out in time and then
the front rotor or the the top rotor was
still at an angle and it hit the
building
that's why you're okay bro yeah
seriously you weren't knocked out from
the boom boom boom I don't know maybe I
was or not but I just remember like
super my head was hurting I just because
I just bounced up and down a few times
you know I'm like dude we gotta get off
and then you helped everybody off yeah I
mean well my whole all our our team had
nods so everybody dropped them off but
the Infantry or the engineer Marines
didn't have any night vision you know
yeah I think like it doesn't even occur
to most of us that in training it can be
more dangerous sometimes than in the
actual Wars I've had so many friends
lost just in training and yeah because
when you mentioned that earlier I was
like wow that's just
I don't think none of us ever think of
anyone dying in training it's like then
you think more people are out there more
like you know getting into more
dangerous situations but it's like wow
yeah
so have you chosen which one you wanted
your dad yeah you gotta pick well Don
was my biological dad yeah and I was
gonna not I was gonna choose a
difference
yeah that's cool yeah that's cool
yeah it's a good choice
foreign